a recent poll found that charitable
giving by americans
is at its lowest level on record which
isn't that surprising
considering the you know pandemic and
unprecedented unemployment crisis
but with illness hunger and social
injustice gripping our country like
never before
it's arguably a terrible time for
donations to
dry up like many of us you may have less
money to part with in these tough times
or
maybe you're one of the lucky ones who
still has a good income
and feel obligated to share the wealth
either way
we can make our charitable dollars go
farther by being smarter
about where we put them
when it comes to charities some are good
some are bad and some are just
flat out scams traditionally the main
factor that determines this is how much
of the money they raise
actually goes to people in need and how
much goes to administration
overhead and fundraising there are lots
of organizations that track these
numbers like
charity navigator or give.org and they
typically consider a charity to be good
if at least 75 percent of the revenue
ends up being spent on aid programs
for example the breast cancer research
foundation spends 88 percent of their
donations on
actual research treatment and aid while
the breast cancer relief foundation
spends only three percent where does the
rest go think
executive salaries luxury offices
marketing budgets and fancy fundraising
parties
and while it's understandable to want as
much of your money going to direct aid
as possible
there are some limitations to judging
charities this way
entrepreneur dan palota argues that the
stigma against
non-profits investing heavily in
salaries and advertising
prevents them from competing for market
share with for-profit companies
this he maintains is why charitable
giving has been stuck at two percent of
gdp for 50 years
and why non-profits have been unable to
solve our biggest
social ills there's also a big
disconnect between the spender of the
money
and the beneficiary of the product if
you buy a 20
takeout meal from a local restaurant you
will know whether you thought the food
was worth the price
but if you donate 20 bucks to a soup
kitchen there's no way for the people it
serves
to tell you how well your money was
spent while there is
room for debate about what constitutes a
good charity
there's no denying that some are
outright scams
these fleeting entities typically
materialize online after a high profile
disaster like hurricane maria's
devastation in puerto rico or
haiti's 2010 earthquake and then quickly
disappear
after collecting thousands or even
millions of dollars
they often directly solicit donations by
email
phone or door to door hoping to
capitalize on people's compassion for
victims
before they had a chance to vet the
organization the fbi estimated that
most of the 4 600 charity websites that
popped up
after hurricane katrina were suspicious
or unverifiable
a good rule of thumb is not to respond
to direct solicitation unless you know
you are dealing with reputable
organization
ask for some literature or website so
that you can investigate the charity
yourself
be aware that scams will often have
names that are very close to familiar
organizations
so the exact wording matters also make
sure you pay securely
like with a credit card or personal
check if a charity asks for donations in
cash
wire transfers or gift cards that may be
a red flag
of course there are exceptions to this
if you have a friend or co-worker who is
raising money on their own for a cause
you can get behind
using cash or venmo is perfectly fine
just know that you're trusting your
friend's administrative skills to get
that money
where it needs to go now that you know
how to avoid suspicious
charities the next question is how to
decide which to support
this is a very personal question
depending on your individual passions
and beliefs
but there are some important factors to
consider first
studies have shown that after a highly
publicized disaster
donations to related charities go up but
charitable giving across the board does
not
this means that americans aren't
necessarily giving extra money to these
charities
but re-routing their usual gift amounts
from
other causes when a lot of people do
that at once non-profit organizations
not associated with a disaster
can suddenly see their revenues drop and
some organizations
may use high profile disasters to raise
more funds than they need
in 2010 doctors without borders stopped
fundraising off the haitian earthquake
because they determined they had enough
money to operate at capacity
but the red cross did not raising almost
half a billion dollars for earthquake
relief
some of that went to plug up their
existing budget deficit and to this day
they have not fully accounted for how
the rest was spent now
we're not saying that you shouldn't give
to big disaster relief projects
but be aware that just because
everyone's intention is focused on a
certain cause
that doesn't mean others have gone away
in fact that may be when
they need the help the most you should
also be aware that americans
overwhelmingly give to american causes
while it's understandable to want to
focus on helping your own country
keep in mind that a dollar goes a lot
farther in
other parts of the world like
sub-saharan africa
the effective altruism movement which
seeks to maximize the impact of
charitable giving
suggests that giving to global health
organizations like anti-malaria
initiatives
provides the most bang for your buck in
terms of alleviating human suffering
deciding how much to give is also a
deeply personal question
but these are the average yearly
charitable donations for each tax
bracket from 2016.
it's generally considered more efficient
to give large amounts to
a few organizations rather than small
amounts to many
the reason for this is processing costs
every time a charity has to digitally
swipe your credit card
it has to pay processing fees if that's
say a dollar per transaction
then a 100 donation is only getting
dinged by one percent
but if you make 10 10 donations suddenly
only
90 of your dollars are actually making
it into the charities bank accounts
perhaps consider doing the 50 30 20 rule
of the total amount that you've decided
to donate but half
into one or two verified charities 30
into community gifts like your church or
school or local food pantry
and 20 into impulse gifts like disaster
relief or
helping out a friend on gofundme and
lastly if you can't give
much or at all this year you can still
help
by sharing and promoting charitable
campaigns
even though it's estimated that less
than 10 of participants in the ice
bucket challenge
actually donated money the als
association
still raised over a hundred million
dollars and that money
directly led to new breakthroughs in
diagnosis
and treatment we know that it's a
strange and scary time for
everyone and it's tempting to squirrel
every time away
in preparation for more bad economic
news but there's also more
need out there than ever before and even
if you can't give as much as you used to
you might be able to make up the
difference by doing it smartly
and that's our two cents thanks to our
patrons for keeping two cents
financially healthy click the link in
the description to become a two cents
patron
you